this is a fox news alert at the top of
the show we told you
the same pentagon that refused during
the last administration to protect
our borders is assisting this
administration the biden administration
in
illegally moving illegal migrants
throughout the country
using military resources specifically at
lachlan air force base but maybe not
just lachlan air force base
so that's what we told you at the top
we've just received during the show
a statement from ice confirming what we
reported
there have been flights of illegal
immigrants
foreign nationals from lachlan air force
base to other destinations within the
united states and we're quoting
on june 17 2021 a memorandum of
agreement or moa between
dhs and dod was signed by all parties in
finalized wish we'd known that
on june 29 2021 ice air operations
utilized lachlan air force base for the
first time pursuant to the moa
to transport non-citizens from cpb
custody to ice custody
since june 29th approximately 780
non-citizens here illegally
were transferred via ice air on six ice
air flights departing for the military
installation
end quote ice also added that
collaboration with federal partners
enables ice to transfer non-citizens
safely and humanely to ice field offices
where the appropriate level of custody
and supervision will be determined
ice air conducts southwest border
flights which involve the transfer of
migrants with cpp custody to ice custody
end quote end of bureaucratic statement
but more questions remain
for example what other military
resources are being used to conduct this
an operation that most americans knew
nothing about
that they did not consent to that
congress never voted on and which is
clearly illegal
and more presently where are these
people going they're being moved
to another form of custody and then
their fate will be determined but where
did they end up
into what communities were they placed
how many federal dollars were spent
doing this did the people into whose
neighborhoods they were placed
have any say in it at all and what's the
total number
fewer than 800 they say from lachlan air
force base between those dates but
what's the total number nationally
why don't we know this whose country is
this who's in charge
you can't just change the composition of
the country breaking federal laws you do
it without asking the people's
permission if you care about
democracy which they clearly don't maybe
we can get some answers like immediately
maybe republicans in congress could wake
up and do that i know we care about cuba
but what about our country
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else